Speaker 1: I told you yesterday on the show
that the Tucker Carlson hour on Fox News lost
about half of its audience in the week after
Tucker Carlson's firing.
Not hugely surprising.
People are tuning in for Tucker, right?
I mean, when I go on vacation, we lose about
50% of our audience as well.
The funny thing is that every guest host that
they seem to try over there seems to just
go worse and worse and worse.
This one is really funny.
Yesterday, the latest attempt at Tucker's
replacement is a guy named Lawrence Jones,
who's worked at Fox News for some period of
time.
He arguably did the worst job of anybody so
far.
He interviewed Asa Hutchinson.
Asa Hutchinson is a Republican candidate.
He's a former Republican governor, Republican
candidate for president for the Republican
nomination.
His campaign is totally dead on arrival.
But they interviewed him anyway.
Fine.
The interview lasted eight and a half minutes.
The interviewer, Lawrence Jones, spoke about
half of that time, more than four of the eight
and a half minutes.
Lawrence Jones was speaking often, yelling
over Asa Hutchinson.
And he tried the Why are you running?
Sort of gotcha.
And when he's saw I mean, listen, I think
the policies are stupid and they're bad policies.
But Asa Hutchinson is naming the things he
did as governor, which Republicans generally
do like.
And Jones tries to short circuit it by saying
every Republican does that stuff.
And it's sort of like, well, what do you want
me to say?
I did the things Republicans like.
Listen to this humiliating attempt at an interview.
Speaker 2: Oh, this is fair.
That that is spin.
The Republicans have said what their position
is.
I understand that you are for free speech
and all of these other issues.
And like I said, respectfully, sir, I understand
it.
You're for economic freedom and all that.
Those are the typical Republican positions,
and that would work.
Back in 2008 or even 2006.
But there there's a different Republican Party
now.
And when I ask you the question, why are you
running?
It seems like you're opposed to all of the
things that the modern day Republican Party
stands for.
What do you say to that?
Well, I disagree with that.
I lowered taxes in Arkansas.
That's a real solution.
Republicans created surpluses.
Lawrence, Lawrence, Lawrence, you've got to
listen to me as well.
You've got to listen as well.
We balanced the budget.
That's what Republicans do.
We lead in this country.
Speaker 1: Yeah, but did you make fun of a
disabled reporter?
Do you pretend do you do you pretend weight
lift to attack trans people during your rallies?
That's what the party wants now.
Speaker 2: Conservative principles.
And whenever you're looking at our values,
I stand second to none in terms of fighting
for pro-life values and conservative values.
Look at my record, Lawrence Governor, and
you'll see that I just went through your record
here.
And as I said, and I gave you credit for the
normal Republican positions.
You're right in line.
But this is a new Republican Party.
Thank you so much for your time, sir.
Speaker 1: All right.
Not exactly a conversation.
I believe that the search continues for a
replacement for Tucker Carlson on Fox News.
If you're curious, you can check out that
that entire interview.
The good news for Lawrence Jones is almost
no one is watching Fox in that timeslot anymore.
So not that many people saw him humiliate
himself.
It's hard to determine who's less ready for
prime time.
Lawrence Jones or Ron DeSantis.
And what he did is he wanted to impress, I
guess, his bosses.
So he came out ready to fight because fight
is good.
But when you just talk over your guest and
you speak for half of the interview, when
you're supposed to be hearing the ideas of
the other person, it just doesn't really work
very well.
And I expect we'll see what the numbers look
like by the end of this week.
I expect that this week's Tucker ratings,
the former lead Tucker ratings will be even
worse than last week.
So Fox News certainly has some problems on
its hands.
I'm not too worried about helping them solve
those problems.
And if you're curious what this interview
look like, we'll have the clip on our Instagram,
which you can find by searching Instagram
for David Pakman show.
We're going to take a quick break.
So much more to discuss
with
you today.